- Hey what's up y'all, I'm
hanging out with Gabriel Iglesias
and Nathan Fillion, give
it up, (makes horn sounds).
And oh, while we're hanging out,
I don't wanna forget Risa
is hanging out right here,
and Vinnie, he brought his dogs today,
so cute, just to make me happy.
We've got so many questions
to get to with Gabriel and
Nathan and so little time.
So let's speed things up with an activity
named in honor of Nathan Fillion,
this is, get it ready, this
is a dad joke for all of them,
yep, Fillion the Blank.
(upbeat music)
Fillion the Blank.
That was awesome, okay.
Here we have our Random
Topic Super-Generator.
Clearly, this is still version 2020,
you can tell because it's a piece of junk
just like the year.
We should update it for 2021, so Justin,
can I get the update?
Let's bring in.
So a marker, cool.
But it's fine, watch this,
we're gonna update it, boom,
and we're gonna go 2021.
I feel better already.
- I do too.
- I also feel kinda high,
this marker is potent, okay.
Okay, I'll hit the
button and the generator,
will bring up a topic, we will all have to
Fillion the Blank.
- That's great.
- All right everybody,
here's the first one, here we go.
Boom.
(machine ringing)
(bing)
Under my bed you will find...
Nathan you can go first.
- An incredibly
comprehensive earthquake kit.
- Nice, I have three of those, yep,
I get really worried about them.
Do you panic about, are
you panicked about it
if it happens?
- Not anymore.
(laughter)
- Well, I have three kits
and I'm still freaking out
when it happens.
Okay, Gabriel, what would you find
under your bed?
- Under my bed you'd find socks.
- Oh, what?
What are you, still 12?
(laughter)
That's like something for a teenage boy,
that's awesome.
- I wish I had something better,
but that's what you're gonna find.
- It's probably just like the one,
the other one is somewhere else.
My dog, Henry sleeps, I don't know why,
on my side of the bed,
and half under the bed
and then his other half sticks out.
I don't know, anyway.
Next one, boom.
(machine ringing)
(bing)
I secretly cry at the movie...
Oh, I'll go with you Nathan,
what do you secretly cry-
- Anything dad,
anything brother, anything family oriented
and the last "Avengers" movie.
I love you 3000.
- Oh, I loved "Endgame."
Okay, that was such a
good one too, I cried too.
Okay, what about you?
- I'm a huge Marvel fan and
I got a little choked up,
but nowhere nearly as choked up as I got
at the movie, "Selena," with J-Lo.
- Oh my gosh, I loved "Selena."
- Yeah.
- They have a new TV series now.
- Yes, on Netflix, just saying,
you could watch right
after "Mr. Iglesias."
- Well I cry at, if you know me at all,
everything, I am touched by all things,
it doesn't matter what it is.
Boom.
(machine ringing)
(bing)
If I could, oh, if I
could go back in time,
I would...
I don't think, I mean, I'm a woman,
so I tend to like the
more progressive time.
So I don't think going
back would be good for me.
(laughter)
I don't think a certain type of person
or being a woman is healthy back in time.
I like now, I like now.
I don't like to live in the past
and I don't regret things, do you?
- You know what, I'm not
gonna say that I don't,
because I think everybody's
guilty of doing it,
at least, a little bit.
But if I could go back in time,
you know what I would do?
I'd probably start working out.
- Okay, so you'd be fit now.
- I'd probably start
working out, I'd be like,
I'm coming to you from burger future.
- Do it.
- Get on that treadmill
right now, trust me.
- Ghost of Christmas future,
I always say that to my kid,
ghost of Christmas future,
just saying.
Nathan, what would you do
if you could back in time?
- The secret of traveling back in time
is don't go too far and bring
winning lottery numbers.
Okay, Nathan wins with that answer,
I'm just gonna say, that
would've solved everything.
- The old "Back to the Future" trick.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that
was nice, that was nice.
- You made a time machine,
you have a DeLorean?
- Marty.
Okay, one more, boom.
(machine ringing)
(bing)
The first thing I wash in the shower is,
well, it's a day time show.
(laughter)
I wash my face
because usually I have makeup on it, so.
What do you do, Gabriel?
- You know what, the first
thing I wash is my feet.
- Your feet?
- The first thing I wash
is my feet, yeah, because I
usually walk around my house
barefoot, and so I'm always like,
let me just make sure that
I get whatever's under there
out of there first.
- Don't you feel like you're
standing in the water,
and like it's kind of
getting done for you?
- I need the scrub feeling.
- Nathan, what about you?
- This is actually very important,
I go top to waist, bottom to up,
and then front and then
back, no cross contamination.
- Oh my gosh, what sign are you?
What's your?
- [Nathan] Aries.
- You're an Aries, okay, 'cause like,
wait, there's a control
factor there, that's a leader,
you're an Aries.
- It's just common sense,
that's just common.
- That's what an Aries
would say, I'm a Taurus.
Anyway, thank you guys
so much for playing,
I think we've learned a lot here.